foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today it's also the co-host of
the smart money happy hour with Rachel
Cruz a very popular podcast of exploding
out there it's a really big deal so
we're here with you to help you today
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're going
to start this hour with Terrain in
Houston hey Terry what's up
foreign
how are you
or we lost her maybe we're off to a
great start maybe we're not okay try
again let's see if I can do that one
more time uh terrain are you there
nope all right all right we're just
gonna start with that then Eric is in
Albany hi Eric welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thank you sir appreciate your taking my
taking my question sure what's up
so
I I I keep getting into my head and
wanting to
liquidate all my investments and pay off
my mortgage
and I I kind of know that like
mathematically that's probably not the
right choice but like I feel like it
would be a major pressure reliever and
then to be able to go back through and
just use all my discretionary cash but
start going back in and rebuilding my
portfolio
so how much do you have in uh your
uh I have my stock portfolio I have what
is uh
180 000 dollars
did you say 180 or did you say 80.
180 000 okay and what's your mortgage
balance
my mortgage balance is like 170. okay
all right and those are the the
portfolio you're discussing is not in a
retirement account correct yeah it's a
taxable account yeah okay and your debt
free other than your home
yeah for the most part I have I have a
credit card that's got a very low
balance on it that I've literally just
charged last month that it paid off by
the end of the month okay and what's
your household income
good for you well done how old are you
I'm 40. okay
and so uh so you're saying that
mathematically it doesn't make sense and
I would even challenge that part I think
mathematically it does make sense to pay
off your house
um
we bought my house in 2012.
we got we got like three and a half
percent interest on it so at this point
I was overpaid on it ever since and paid
bi-weekly yeah and so at this point I'm
like not really paying any any interest
on it and what interesting and pain is
is minimal
um versus the returns that I've been
able to get in the stock market
um you know but you've not factored in
Risk
right there's no math for risk in your
formula
and not factoring in Risk mathematically
is a naive formula
and um so here's what we know we know
from the data of studying millionaires
that the typical millionaire does two
things that causes them to get to their
first one to five million dollars that
they get out of debt house and
everything and they build their 401K in
the Roth IRAs and good growth stock
mutual funds the number of millionaires
that we asked that said and we said okay
did you
leverage your home in order to invest in
stocks and that's why you became a
millionaire the number of them that say
that is very close to zero
they say stuff like well Lord no I got
out of debt
isn't that interesting
so the formula that you're proposing is
mathematically correct
um is not used by hardly any
millionaires to get to millionaire
status
Translation your formula is wrong
so Eric would you take out against your
home a hundred eighty thousand dollar
loan to invest into single stocks
that's it you know if if that what I was
doing for for a living yeah sure why not
but if you were day trading for a living
basically
uh yeah um you also probably wouldn't be
sleeping at night you'd lose
relationships because you'd be staring
at these numbers making sure they go up
all the time you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right about that so
there's a piece of this where man I can
feel it you're craving that peace but
you're stuck on the Starry Eyed but what
if I got this return on that money and
the guaranteed return in your house I
think is way more valuable so here's
what I would do you called us and so I
really really simply I would cash out
the stock and pay off the house today
now then I don't have a house payment I
have an increased
stability
at the very Foundation of my life and my
financial plan because I you you cannot
grasp and you actually can't
mathematically capture that it feels
different to walk through your backyard
with no shoes on the grass feels
different when you don't have a mortgage
you cannot capture that you cannot
capture what this does that the stress
release even if it's minor what that
does for your relationships you cannot
capture what it does for your boldness
and Your Excellence in your career and
all of those things over time the math
actually plays out
to that people of means people of wealth
actually do not take out home mortgages
to trade themselves buy and sell single
stocks those are called day Traders 78
of which lose money and um lose a lot of
other things while they're doing it so
George you want to hear about the ones
that win well and you'll and they're
always temporary because you know it's
the same thing as playing the slots oh I
wanted the slots right yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's how they built those certain
casinos okay not by you winning at the
slots I can tell you that so
mathematically just because you hit it
once doesn't mean you're gonna so all
that to say Eric I'm going off the data
of the 30 years of doing what I do
walking alongside people watching their
lives transform watching their
relationships their careers Blossom uh
and their portfolio because when you
don't have a house payment and you make
260 000 a year you can build up 180 000
bucks really quick if you want to screw
around single stocks won't take long at
all so good question thank you for
calling pay off your house today sir
yeah the whole end goal of both of our
discussions is build wealth the question
is what is the best path to do it and we
have found that doing it with the least
amount of risk possible puts you in a
better financial position long term and
so what we're saying here is you're
going to build wealth either way you
could lose your butt hanging on to these
single stocks in the next week depending
on who tweets what or you could have a
guaranteed return with no house payment
making 260 thousand dollars you think
you can build wealth with that situation
absolutely a hundred percent of the time
you can so uh and a hundred percent of
the foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage so didn't have to do a lot of
research on that it'll come to you later
I promise uh so that's the idea folks
that's the idea what is your most
powerful wealth building tool
is it your home equity nope
it's your income
the person in your mirror is the secret
sauce for you to build wealth free to
build a quality life you're the secret
sauce you're the answer no one's going
to do it for you
and there is no magic pill that you've
yet to discover just go go in there
brush the fog off of the mirror after
the shower and look at that guy look at
that gal and go you're the problem
you're the solution
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com save
up to 45 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today well a lot has changed
over the years here on the Ramsey show
but our practical advice on life and
money never has I can tell you that for
over 30 years millions and millions of
folks have tuned into the Ramsey Show
for money relationships career and life
advice and whether people up to their
eyeballs in debt and wondering how they
can't get ahead or they spending their
days in a dead end j-o-b I'm trying to
find Hope trying to find a way well
we're excited to announce that the
Ramsey show is now also on TBN and you
can tune into the Ramsay show on TBN
weekdays at 5 PM Eastern 4 P.M Central
get your daily dose of Life money career
and relationship advice hey be sure and
jump in there we'll see you then George
Campbell Ramsey personalities my co-host
today and I think we've got to Ray in
Houston lined up now hey terrie how are
you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
well thank you guys for taking my call
to start
um so basically I purchased a home my
first home back in October and I am now
experiencing buyer's remorse
it's just been a lot of if it's nothing
it's something everything's broken
everything needs to be fixed everything
needs to be replaced
um
and so I guess my question is if I did
not make the best decision how do I make
the best decision moving forward in
rectifying controlling and maintaining
my financial responsibilities
to build and so forth
so is this a fixer-upper that you bought
like are these shocking repairs or do
you know some of this going in
no um it basically that it's a house
that was built in 83 and a lot of the
renovations that were done were poorly
done
okay and this buyer's remorse is this
coming from the mortgage payment being
too big or is it all these repairs that
you don't have the cash to do where is
that coming from both both I feel like
I'm paying too much on my mortgage for
all of the repairs that I'm ending up
having to take care of now that I've
moved in hmm
so how much is your house payment
five okay and what's your take-home pay
a month
your house payment's not too high
it's okay so that's not a problem you're
just not used to paying a house payment
yet okay but it's it's in the zone of
it's it's less than a fourth of your
take-home pay so you're fine what do you
do for a living to rent
I recruit for oil and gas good for you
okay well
um what uh
what I think is going to happen is
um that you're probably going to get the
other side of the bulk of these repairs
I don't know what exactly you've had to
fix or do what what are some examples of
the three biggest
most worrisome things that and the cost
of them that you had to fool with
to start planning is the roof
as well the majority of the appliances
that look to be new are having to be
replaced
insulation is completely poor I have to
have someone to come in and look at that
so those right now are just a few of the
things that I'm trying to work on okay
who told you that the roof had to be
replaced
um at the time when I first moved in um
I did use my VA home loan so the
inspector that the VA sent out he was
very particular about the roof and that
was the major concern when it came to
you know finalizing the purchase
it wasn't a concern enough that the VA
appraiser required a roof
right if it was bad VA would have
required a roof or they wouldn't have
put the loan on it
okay so now who told you there's it
needs a roof is it leaking
um we had a a technician come out during
Christmas because the AC was a problem
and he told me that it was it was
leaking around somewhere in the Attic
which was causing mold or some sort he
was just like it's not major but it is
something that I wanted to look into I'm
very um I'm an overthinker
um this like I said this is my first
home I'm new to all of this so I I'm
panicking right now yeah and I'm just
trying to stay on top of everything yeah
so you're a self-admitting
that you're catastrophizing okay the guy
went up there the guy went up there and
he said there's a leak and a little bit
of mold you need to get that looked at
and you went I gotta get a whole
room right possibly so yes yeah I mean
that's what I heard I might be wrong and
I I do that too that's how I can
recognize it so um we all have a drama
queen that lives inside of us every one
of us and part part of making good
decisions you ask how to make good
decisions is to tell the drama queen to
shut up
um and that you know that's part of it
you got to look at yourself and go
you're you're really come on so yeah you
probably do need to get that roof looked
at but it might be a few hundred dollars
instead of ten thousand to put on an
entire roof
it might need a little bit of a shingle
replacement there or there might be a
leak around one of the vents and they
put a new boot on it and caulk it up and
you're just fine so a good handyman
getting up there and fixing that one
area and you know shooting some stuff
killing the mold in that one little area
uh so it doesn't get worse and you don't
go up there later and the whole attic
has grown full or something like that so
yeah address it but don't over think it
and then you know all of the appliances
need look new but need to be replaced
are they not working
absolutely not what's not working your
dishwasher doesn't work
no dishwasher stove refrigerator nothing
none of them work
no did the inspector catch any of this
no did you have a home inspection
yes I had two home inspections and I had
a gas leak that was so extreme I
couldn't stay in my house for two days
and I didn't know like how I asked how
did y'all miss this
okay so your home inspector is an idiot
okay yeah obviously right I mean you
miss a gas leak and and appliances that
don't work that's a basic thing you go
through and turn on all the appliances
this basic home inspection stuff okay so
the great news is you make good money
your house payment's not out of control
you probably don't need an entire roof
you do need a new dishwasher have you
asked Appliance to repair people to come
and just repair the existing ones or are
you just planning to replace them
completely
um I was trying to see if I had some
type of ability through my homeowners
insurance
um if that could be rectified with them
um no it's not so I'm going to have to
pay homeowners insurance doesn't cover
your dishwasher not working
so just have a guy come out and either
look at it and fix it or replace it a
few hundred bucks I mean they're not
they're not ten thousand dollars do you
have any other debt to Ray
um outside of my a little credit card
debt and a few thousand old on my car no
that's it okay and when it comes you
said we you have a spouse involved here
uh did I say we I do apologize okay it's
just you you're single okay yeah so
here's what I want you to do uh what's
happening is all of these things are up
flying around and and and just about the
time you wake up in the morning or by
the time you're about to doze off at
night they're overwhelming instead what
I want you to do is just write down a
list of what needs to be repaired and
what you're going to do about it
okay Sean okay dishwasher I'm gonna call
a repairman and if it can't be repaired
cheaply I'm going to replace it
refrigerator I'm going to call a
repairman if it can't be repaired
cheaply I'm going to replace it roof I'm
going to have a handyman type come out
not a roofer trying to sell me a roof
that just looks at it finds the one
little leak fixes the one little leak
and sprays some stuff and kills the mold
okay and you just you develop a list
with an action plan and when the weird
thing is if you'll write it down
literally on a yellow pad a little
repair to-do list
then you're going to look at it and it's
gonna
suck the drama out of your brain
and it's going to drop right there on
that page because you're going to go oh
this is doable how because it when it
all comes at you at once it's
overwhelming creates anxiety when you
break it down into bite-sized pieces one
task at a time one broken thing at a
time you can work through an entire
remodel doing that and you don't have an
entire room we're just exchanging the
boogeyman for the repairman yeah that's
the switch here this is the your first
experience being a homeowner where you
don't call the landlord and say your
stuff's broke
instead you've got to take care of it
when it breaks it's one of the reasons
we say get out of debt have an emergency
fund before you become a homeowner
homeowner because all the stuff would
have been an inconvenience at that point
and you know you make enough money to
get through this I and no you don't need
to sell your house and really you don't
even need to have buyer's remorse I mean
there's a couple of weird things that
are here the inspector missing this
stuff but nothing here says this house
is a lemon that you're the biggest
screw-up in life because you bought it
you're a horrible person I didn't hear
any of that in this discussion you got a
couple of things broken fix them joys of
home ownership and your payment's
reasonable
fix your dishwasher enjoy the house it's
that kind of stuff just kind of put the
drama out of it put it down on the page
break it down into bite-sized pieces
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phone's a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well in the uh Twilight uh the end as
2022 is coming to a close Congress
passed a
massive spending bill of course
because that's what you should do if
you're in Congress and uh but a good the
good news is as a part of that they also
passed what is appropriately called the
secure
Act of 2022 2.0 so what is the secure
act 2.0 well it changes a bunch of
things in your retirement and a couple
of things in your student loans as well
and a good blog at ramseysolutions.com
right now very good detail on this
unpacked uh if you want to get in there
and really look at it and plug around I
think we post those blogs on Facebook
too if I remember James and uh but
George I want to take a minute since
that blog's out there and you guys can
go through it all and and look at it in
detail but for those of you that don't
make it over the blog let's hit the
highlights yeah there's a ton in here
that really help a lot of people with
their retirement I mean it's secure act
stands for setting every Community up
for retirement enhancement so kudos to
the marketing team that got to create
that little acronym there yeah well good
luck with that part but anyway it's good
it's good updates there's some things
that needed to happen yeah so it's
starting with required minimum
distributions you'll hear these called
rmds the age is rising to 73 instead of
72 which means you have an extra year
without the government tapping you to
get some of their cash yeah it required
minimum distributions are your 401k your
Roth or your not Roth your traditional
IRAs they require you to start taking
money out at a minimum schedule so they
can tax it and it used to be 70 and a
half then it moved to 72 and with this
it moves to 73. so you can leave your
money alone and not touch it until 73
now that's good next one no more
required minimum distributions from Roth
401ks and Roth 403bs so this one's
interesting because you've already paid
the taxes on it so they're saying you've
already paid the taxes you can just have
it it doesn't do anything to force you
to start taking it out on rmds so we're
going to let you just let it sit there
and grow tax-free another reason to love
a Roth that's great next up smaller
penalties for missed required minimum
distributions it was 50 it's coming down
to 25 percent now if you miss your rmds
yeah good next higher catch-up
contributions on the way so if you're 50
years or older there's a lot of great
ways you can step up your retirement you
know put an extra thousand in your IRA
for example an extra 5 000 extra 7 500
in your 401ks and they're increasing
that yeah 60 to 63 beginning in 25 not
in 2025 January 1 if you're aged 6 to 6
60 to 63 you'll be able to put ten
thousand dollars annually into a
workplace retirement plan an additional
ten thousand dollars and so it allows
you if you're quote running behind is it
too late for me this is for you right
love it all right next up on the good
news front easier access to retirement
funds for emergencies what is it not
good news that's one of the downers of
this plan here we were doing so great
Dave yeah we're on a great ball a
thousand until we got to stupid land and
so here's what this means uh starting in
2024 you can withdraw up to a thousand
dollars from your retirement account for
personal or family emergencies if you've
been listening to the show for more than
10 seconds you'll know that you should
never tap your retirement accounts for
emergencies yeah you should have an
emergency fund and leave your freaking
retirement account alone and let it grow
and make you rich absolutely all right
here's an interesting one curious to get
your take on this Dave employers must
automatically enroll you into a
workplace retirement plan
this is Nanny State stuff holding your
hand this is uh we're going to take care
of you because you're too stupid to take
care of yourself idea and so now when
you join a company that has a 401k the
company is required to sign you up for
the 401K automatically at an automatic
minimum contribution rate of three
percent and if you don't want that to
happen you have to opt out manually go
in and opt out you have to stop it from
occurring uh so that's too much control
it's got a good intent I want everybody
to have a retirement account that's a
good thing yes you need to be in your
401k but let's say you're working the
baby steps you would need to opt out but
if you're not doing 401K because you're
on baby step two well and the other
problem is if you are in a place to
invest you've got three percent you
don't realize it you need to up that to
15 if you're out of debt with a fully
funded emergency fund yeah so be sure
you pay attention to that stuff don't
don't you know
we're from the government and we're here
to help these are scary words okay a
three percent rate is not going to get
you very far in retirement so we've got
to do better for sure uh next this has
been one of uh some hot debate employers
can match your student loan payments
with retirement contributions
it's confusing yes so this sounds like
they're paying your student loans now
some employers are now offering a
benefit that has nothing to do with this
just where they will help you pay your
student loans off one way or another
whatever it is they'll give you they'll
match you they'll do whatever has
nothing to do with anything as far as
this stuff goes this
is not that this is you pay up to three
thousand dollars on your student loan
and your employer puts up to three
thousand dollars into your 401k
which doesn't it's just wouldn't that
incentivize you to never pay off your
student loans we want you to eat apples
so we're going to chop oranges
it's just weird it's it you mix these
things up and and people are getting
confused about already they think it
means the government's going to pay part
of your student or the employer is going
to pay part of your student loan and
match you on what you're putting on your
student loan they're not they have to
put in the 401K so it's weird it's
because anything that gets more money
against your student loan or causes you
to do that anything that gets more money
into your retirement I'm for all of that
but this is just convoluted and weird
well wouldn't you be pissed if you
already paid off your student loans or
didn't have any and Joe schmo's next to
you is getting an extra three grand in
his 401k that's a benefit though that's
your employer offering a benefit the
employer is not required to offer this
benefit I'm curious to see how many
employers do this yeah I don't think
they'll well you never know you never
know out there all right next up you can
roll over unused 529 plan funds to a
Roth IRA ding ding this one's good this
one I love because that's been a big you
know point of objection people go well
Dave what if my kid doesn't go to
college they don't use all the money
that money is just wasted yeah it's not
you yeah after 15 years your kid head
throws it into their Roth IRA no
penalties up to the annual contribution
so you put a hundred thousand hundred
fifty thousand bucks into a uh 529 uh
kid uses 75 or 80 000 of it whatever's
left in there sits there 15 years
growing tax-free in good mutual funds
and then they roll it into a Roth IRA
into good mutual funds and it continues
to grow tax-free no penalties that one
I'm a huge fan of I love this one this
is a fun one too Roth options are now
available for simple IRAs and sep IRAs
so folks that are self-employed business
owners this is cool I'm confused I
thought that was already there
yeah I'm not sure they didn't already
have that but I could be wrong so it's
good though yeah the simple IRA is
simply a 401k for small business uh and
the SEP IRA is a uh the simpler the
simple incentive match plan for it's
it's best used by a uh a solopreneur
because if you have employees you have
to put the same amount in you got to put
it for yourself so we'd seldom use
Sapphire as much but simple hours are
great for small businesses to open up
and now they can do a Roth that's good
news and lastly new emergency savings
account option alongside retirement
accounts so this one's a little
different than the previous one
um but it's saying that the employer can
set aside up to 2500 annually for
non-highly compensated employees in a
separate emergency savings alongside
their retirement account so it's a
little sidecar here yeah but is it
invested and the problem is 2500 is not
enough for an emergency fund so then
you've got the Thousand you can take out
of your 401k for your emergency and
you've got it all over at the employer
and so people get the idea oh my
emergency fund's taken care of it's not
it's not enough money there's very few
of you that three to six months of
expenses represents 2500 bucks so this
is a this is one of those head fakes
that the government's saying hey look we
did something and you didn't want to do
anything because it's not it's not
sufficient to cover it now they could do
up to ten thousand dollars in there or
something that might cover some people's
you know emergency not enough to to do
any damage I wouldn't use this instead
of your emergency phone and I wouldn't
use the option to cash money out of your
401k for emergencies either as your
emergency fund I wouldn't do either one
I'd leave all of that alone well credit
where credits do there's a lot of wins
in here and you guys can check out the
entire article we've got it linked in
the show notes wherever you're listening
of course at ramseysolutions.com but I
need her to win today I'm going to call
this a win I'm gonna call it a win we
pick on and we can even allow uh
President Joe Biden to call a win he
signed it I'm sure he's already tweeted
it he signed it and so he gets a win on
that way to go President Biden you don't
hear that often from Dave not not at
often at all can't shoot down a balloon
but you can sign this this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
thanks for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Nick is with us Nick is in
Louisville Kentucky hi Nick how are you
now I'm hanging in there like a hair in
a Biscuit love it how can we help
brother
um I've recently started uh following
you on YouTube and I'm trying to figure
this all out I don't know if you go over
it in your uh school and or college
whatever it's called University
but I have a question about tithing I've
been able to do it pretty well and
on my tax return I know you say that
it's just a refund but am I supposed to
tithe on it
oh your tax refund would you tithe on it
uh if you've tithed on your total income
no because that's just your money coming
back to you
let's say that you're tithe on your
total income and you took five thousand
dollars and put it in a savings account
when you took the five thousand dollars
out of the savings account you wouldn't
pay tithe on it
because it had already been tithed on
before you put it in there a tax refund
is exactly the same thing if you're
tithing on your gross uh income are you
before before tax or after tax
ES
after tax
yeah
let's see so well I mean uh let me think
how the math would work then so the
refund what comes in
what you actually get in your hand is
what you're talking about what I get in
my hand whether it be a bonus or
anything
and you paid too much in
which would have if you had brought that
home you would have brought more home in
that case you would tithe on the refund
because if it was set up properly and no
refund that money would have come home
and you would have tithed on it
right does that make sense
yeah so you're tithing up you're tithing
on take-home pay right
and your your take-home pay is too low
that's why you got a refund
because you had too much taken out of
your taxes so if you correct this and
had a zero refund you would be bringing
home more the equivalent of that refund
does that make sense right
right that's right it's a math riddle is
all it is but so let me let me just use
that as an opportunity then to you know
to go back to what we cover in Financial
Peace University on tithing obviously
tithing is something it's a Biblical uh
guideline for giving a tenth of your
income uh typically it's uh observed by
Evangelical Christians like me and
George and you Nick I assume and by uh
uh Orthodox Jews
Jewish uh tradition also respects and
endorses the tithe as well because it's
an Old Testament item it's their Bible
our Old Testament so where it comes from
so having said all of that uh just let
everybody know this is not like a uh uh
and I don't I don't sense this off of
you Nick I'm just using the fact that
you asked the question as an opportunity
to talk about a little bit but uh uh it
you never tithe from a legalism
standpoint or this makes God love me
more or he owes me something back
because I tithe at the standpoint this
is simply me being obedient to my faith
and this is a baseline of giving to do a
rhythm of giving and a lot of people
tithe uh I tithe on my gross before
taxes
not after tax and that in the point
though is it doesn't matter uh because
God's not mad at you or mad or more
pleased with me because I gave more
that's not how this works this is he our
heavenly father who loves us is trying
to teach us to be generous
and so a part of our rhythm is we make
money we give some of it we make money
we give some of it we make money we give
some of it and that's why the tithe is
tied into our spiritual walk uh if
you're not a Christian and you're out
there you're not Jewish and you're out
there you still need to observe
something like this to create to build
your generosity muscle on a rhythm basis
not on an occasional random basis so
really really good question Nick yeah
it's nuanced and the heart is the real
issue and Nick's got that part taken
care of yeah the motive is great he's
just wondering the nuances of this I'm
confused by and you've always said in
FPU gross net we can have discussions
all day and play on the gross and that
way when I get to heaven if I'm wrong
I'm on the upside right so it's a joke
it's a joke okay so here's yeah but it's
always first in the budget for a good
reason it's a reminder God does not need
your money he's God
he if he wants something to happen he'll
do it you don't have to worry about it
this is about him teaching you how to be
generous him teaching you how to build
your generosity muscle by working it out
every time there's a paycheck I lift
that generosity up I lift it I do it and
it becomes a part of your life
interesting study I read years ago
George on this it's a worth sidebarring
on because generosity is really the
reason to build wealth change your
family tree take care of your your
family your kids your grandbabies that
kind of stuff a Godly Man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
um and so inheritance is a Biblical
process and also to be unbelievably
outrageously generous and to push all
that through but one of the studies I
found was they they interviewed people
uh asking them
uh
tell me about
generosity tell me about a time that
generosity is in your life and when they
interviewed old people of Faith they
talked about a lifetime of this rhythm
of giving steadily over time
when they interviewed middle people
middle-aged people they talked about the
one time that they gave something
when they interviewed extremely young
people like teens and even children when
they asked them about generosity they
described a time they received something
and the point being that as you
emotionally mature hopefully spiritually
mature you're going to start to realize
what Nick is doing is whether you're a
person of Faith or not it is a it's a
part of your emotional maturity Journey
because the more mature people are the
ones that described a steady diet a
steady life of outgoing generosity the
children received described receiving
something and so adults devise a plan
and follow what children do it feels
good even applies to generosity man
that's incredible well and it's such a
great piece when we talk about there's
only three things you can do with money
it's a tool you can give it save it and
spend it and you've said that giving is
the most fun you can have with money it
just makes you more of who you are and
so if you're a generous person when
you're broke you're going to be real
generous when you've got some money yeah
it increases your creativity increases
the quality of your relationships
there's all kinds of data that your
quality of life goes up and your
probability of wealth building goes up
as you increase your when you live
longer science is showing it's it's
lowers your blood pressure to be
generous exactly it's amazing it really
does because you're other centered
instead of self-centered also for that
reason generous people are more
attractive
uh people you want to be around them not
because they're giving you money but
just because they're they're the person
that hold the door they're the person to
help you pick up your groceries when
they spill out them all those stupid
bags and roll all over the parking lot
right well I found they're less stressed
yeah that's amazing love it love it love
it so that's the thing so Nick really
good question thanks for letting us have
that uh as an excuse to get up on our
generosity Soap Box because I gotta tell
you very few times do selfish people
make you cry
but generous people will make your eyes
leak
when you start watching someone do
something generous it it gets up in your
throat and you feel it your throat gets
tight and you're like ah man that's just
that's just and you're not even
necessarily focusing on that person
going oh that person's so cool you're
saying what they're doing is so cool and
there's three types there's planned
generosity which is great they're
spontaneous generosity which can make us
cry but then there's outrageous
generosity which is where the tears are
just streaming down her face as we see
the video on social media and there's
such a beauty and joy to it and we could
all use a little bit more of that this
year yeah mind-blowing generosity that
last one I like it just blows somebody's
mind and you know have this opportunity
to do something that is
it's just unbelievable she's like wow
and that that was her get yourself in a
position to have those moments and man
when you're broke and all you're doing
is paying payments to stupid MasterCard
and Ford Motor Credit uh you're not
thinking about other people all you're
thinking about yourself and it's because
you're trying to freaking survive it's
not because you're a bad person but the
more you get in control the more you put
together a plan the more you can be
other centered and it works it's good
and everyone needs to go watch lesson
nine of Financial Peace University where
you talk about this it is man gets me
every time it's a good lesson this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Brenda starts off this hour in San Diego
hi Brenda how are you hi I'm wonderful I
feel blessed to be able to talk to you
today well you too how can we help
um well my husband and I are trying to
do kind of a retirement Sprint and so we
moved to San Diego to increase our
income
we have a home where we uh in the
midwest that's fully paid for and so we
will be out here three to five more
years and we're wondering about the
wisdom of buying a condo or something
instead of paying rent I know there's
different rules for a second home
um but I I'm just not sure in that short
time period with all the closing costs
and everything
um I wanted to know what you'd advise
this is your residence for now because
you're living there
exactly for another three to five years
we've been renting for about a year when
we moved out here my husband was a
contractor and got a very generous
housing allowance
um but now as an employee and I'm also
an employee
um we have about fourteen thousand
dollars a month after expenses
um or about income and then after
expenses including fully maxing our our
401s at work and everything we have
about an extra 8 000 a month so we could
really
to really pack on the house payments but
then in about five years we would want
to sell we wouldn't want to have a
rental that far away exactly and I don't
think it makes sense to have a second
home that far away so you're going to
buy it when you're going to sell it when
you leave
if that makes sense that's the only
thing that would make that's the only
thing that's the only way it makes sense
you're not going to buy it and keep it
okay so that tells us what our math
formula is then
is the house going to go up or the condo
going to go up in value during three
years enough
to pay the expenses when you sell it and
still make a profit
for a few years and the because the
we're looking at six to seven hundred
thousand dollar townhouse which is a
modest
um in the area we are definitely and you
know you're looking at quite a bit of
closing costs and property tax and
insurance and everything and right now
our rent is 3 600 a month
um which isn't a nice safe area and we
are paying a little more than we should
but you know we've we've got money in
the bank homes are paid off so that was
one of the things we're doing for
ourselves
um so but we would be looking at you
know around four to five thousand
dollars a month at least on a 15-year
loan and I I just am not sure that it
pencils out and so I since you guys are
such wonderful math quizzes I thought I
would pick your brain so how much money
do you guys have in cash non-retirement
uh right now about 240. okay and that
includes your emergency fund so you'd
put the majority of that as a down
payment
I just put 80 the other day in a four
percent CD
um kind of as our emergency fund because
we had so much and that's part of the
reason I'm calling now is we're getting
an uncomfortably large amount of money
not which we've never had before in our
lives
um not doing a whole lot for us right
um so we would need to invest this
somehow and of course the Market's down
quote unquote and things are on sale
um so we could definitely do that
um you know we've never had this
situation before you know what it
started out great for 10 years and then
kind of fell off the wagon for 10 years
and now we're trying to Sprint into
retirement
um but we are baby step Millionaires and
so I feel like we have choices which is
such a great place to be I don't think
you're going to get rich buying this
condo and I don't think you're going to
uh save enough if you don't buy it to
get rich so it's more of do I want to be
an owner oh out there in California
during this time because I mean San
Diego is a great Market it's going to do
well uh real estate we're predicting
nationally is going to go up three to
seven percent a year for the next three
or four years San Diego will probably do
more than that
which will be enough for you to break
even or make a profit but you're not
going to make a ton of money or it's
like oh I'm so happy I did this it
changed my life it's not going to happen
and you're not going to lose enough
either that it's going to change your
goals here
which kind of makes me think I might
just rent just because of the hassle
and that's kind of where I'm at because
even if we just make a little bit yeah
when you you're looking at six percent
clothing closing costs and taxes because
we've already taken our um what is that
one time when you sell a house and and
you get a certain allowance no you get
that you get that every two years
oh you do okay okay well we could take
that it's your personal if it's your
personal residence you can make up to a
half million dollars filing jointly if
you've owned the house two years
even if it's not your only residence it
is your permanent residence this is
where you live but it's it's it's not
because well yes it is our permanent
resident that we'll move back to to
retire in is still back there you live
there another state you live there full
time you live there this is your
residence
you establish residents so there's no
question about that you that'll pass the
smell test on that taxes all of that
said though you're probably going to
take on a bigger payment and the hassle
of home ownership and the hassle of
having to divest the condo get rid of it
when you move again and all of this for
50 or 60 Grand or something and I'm just
not going to fool with it if I were you
I'd just stay there and rent and just
enjoy this life is simple when you're a
renter
yes I I'm enduring that part and I I
think that five years of a couple
hundred thousand dollars in Investments
would be more than that 50 Grand yeah
yeah I think you're going to do just
fine the market goes down I think it
will go up higher than that yeah and if
you buy if you if you enjoy Real Estate
and you want to buy some real estate
back home after you get back there
you're gonna have some money to do that
with so
you know after you after you have to
finish the San Diego Adventure you're
out so but for now I mean I would I'd
Park that money I don't love the idea of
the CD as your emergency fund because
it's locked up in the CD and if you take
that money out early there's going to be
some penalties but you could invest the
money like Dave said into the market and
take 200 of that and you could make some
money off of that you could park it in a
high old savings account and make you
know four percent right now
um but I wouldn't just let it sit in the
account either
so do something make a move you know
absolutely absolutely so hey good
question good discussion thank you for
calling in open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk to
you about your life and your money it's
a free call hey Financial Peace
University is up and running if you want
to get into a class now is the time to
do it if you've uh your resolution uh
needs to be resolutioned well we can
help you with that we'll get you out of
debt help you build some wealth go to
ramseysolutions.com
FPU class and get into a Financial Peace
University class right now this is the
class that's helped 10 million people
really do this
ramseysolutions.com FPU class
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go go to netsuite.com Ramsay today
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Georgia Campbell Ramsey personality is
my co-host today welcome to the Ramsey
Show let's face it taxes are confusing
and if you buy what some of the tax
services out there say you think you
never get a grasp on taxes you have to
have somebody do it for you because
you're too stupid well we don't think
that
today's tax tip
we think you can do it we think you're
smarter than that and you deserve the
truth most tax software exists for one
reason to take your money they feed you
to death with up charges processing fees
and they want to sell you into buying
debt they're trying to they use the tax
software to gather your name and sell to
you then
but now you can say no more
take control of your taxes use the
services on your side like Ramsey smart
tax it guides you through the process of
filing online with low upfront brushing
no hidden fees no sneaky offers to put
you into debt Ramsay smart tax gives you
two easy ways to file they both include
all major federal forms and deductions
from the start which can save you up to
70 percent versus using other software
so you just decide the level of support
you want for your questions and you can
add a state return if you need to
ramseysolutions.com slash smart tax it's
easy
and you're smart enough to do it
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax Vixen St Louis hi Vic welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey good afternoon I hope your
Wednesday's going well it is brother how
can we help
for the Air Force nearby I'm invested in
the Thrift Savings Plan and I'm also
familiar with with your mutual fund
investing strategy and across equally
across the four types of funds I'm
looking to retire in about four years
and tell direct transfer you know
equally into those funds but my question
pertains to when it comes to taking the
distributions how do I do that do I
equal withdrawals or is there a
situation where maybe I don't want to
take as much out of say the growth in
income or the international I was just
wondering if you could speak to that a
little bit I didn't really see anything
on your your website about that
the truth is it doesn't matter much
um what you need to do is just to figure
out what you how much money you need
coming home and just have that amount
come out of whichever funds you want to
pick you can have it done easily across
the entire Air Force so it's probably
not going to be a lot it'll just be
whatever the required minimum
distribution happens to be yeah and you
won't have that till 73. right so even
then when you get there what how much
would you take or what are you going to
take you're going to take you set set
your required minimums or set an amount
or percentage whichever one you want to
do and you can have it come across all
of them equally or you can have it come
from one until it's gone and leave all
the others in place like if you have a
fund that's really cooking and you like
it uh maybe you leave it alone and you
drain off some of the others right you
know that's okay uh you can sit down
with your smartvestor pro at that time
and they'll help you develop a strategy
but there's not a right or wrong thing
here it's not like oh well you
absolutely need to go ahead and you know
drain that dog fund off and you know let
that one that's cooking real good let it
keep going that's not a bad plan it's
not the end of the world but you've
already made it by then
so you're in good shape you're making
money you've you know you've built some
wealth now it's just a matter of
maximizing it and uh and so forth so
you're right you're you're probably not
actually going to be taking anything
until you're forced to it's a good
problem to have yeah that's a great
problem to have and thank you for your
service fix absolutely Tyler is with us
Tyler is in Chicago hey Tyler welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so uh me and my wife are
having some disagreements on how we want
to go about paying off uh our debts you
know I'm I'm a heavy Dave Ramsey
listener I listen to you guys all the
time and I follow the baby steps whereas
she's
um she's
been raised her whole life to believe
you know just pay the minimum payment
until it's all paid off that way so I'm
wondering A Way Forward on how we can
agree on how to attack our debt this is
a fun one so how much debt do you guys
have
So currently I have a truck loan with
about 1300 left on it and we have both
have student loans at about 8 000 a
piece
and that's everything
that's everything okay what's your
income what's your household income
so I'm active duty Navy so I make around
I made uh around 46 000 last year
and is she working outside the home
uh no she's a stay-at-home mom we we
have a four-month-old daughter okay
so we're looking at seventeen thousand
dollars in debt with a forty six
thousand dollar income
correct
this feels like a solvable problem uh
but it sounds like she doesn't want to
get out of debt if you're just making
the minimum payments you're talking
about you know a 10 20 year payoff plan
interest causing the loan to balloon
exactly I mean I've I've laid every bit
of evidence and piece of information out
showing I mean I made a debt payoff
tracker I made a very detailed budget
for us to go off of and but this isn't a
disagreement on how to get out of debt
it's a disagreement on should we get out
of debt
exactly so does she feel are you feeling
the pressure is she feeling the pressure
of this debt in your life
are you guys living your best life
I mean yeah we we save a lot of money I
mean we we have about 30 000 in our
savings account right now so you can pay
it off today we're not hurting at all
but she's she's more concerned about
investing now
because she's she's uh she's really big
on investing she's been doing it for a
long time she's more worried about
getting
money and Investments now and paying off
debts later rather than vice versa like
how I believe
how old are you guys
I am 26 and she's 24.
um
so here's the thing
uh
she's broke
and 24 years old
so her your plan's not working
and she's not big on investing she's not
old enough to have been big on investing
very long
a maximum of a few years
and so you got thirty thousand dollars
in savings it's not about Dave Ramsey
it's not just about getting out of debt
and it's not about the Ramsay way or
something like that the question on the
table should be
that the two of you need to consider
is what is the shortest right way
to build wealth and what is the data
to back that up
okay there is zero research that
indicates her process is going to work
there's zero evidence that rich people
do it the way she's talking about none
none
so it's not going to do with me or you
or is my way right your ways right it's
a matter of the data when you when you
study millionaires you don't find any of
them became millionaires doing what
she's talking about doing instead they
almost unanimously agree
I mean and you know 79
92 percent agree
that the way we got wealthy is we got
out of debt so we had more money to
invest
absolutely and and
you know that's that's the point that
I've been trying to make for the longest
time yeah and and so you know her theory
is just that it's a theory
and there's no data to back up that
she's right
so I'm not sure where all this arrogance
is coming from at 24 years old
I mean how much are you guys investing
right now
um so
I currently do so I have tsp through the
military I I do 10 with the five percent
match
and she recently rolled over her uh
her retirement from her last job into a
Roth IRA and we're investing in that and
that has about two thousand dollars in
it and show her on paper here's what
it's going to cost us an interest to pay
off this debt over the next 20 years and
here's how much we could make in the
market if we paid off the debt today
invested that payment and still had 13
Grand left over in savings
yeah she wants to argue with math that's
the way to do it but I think it's beyond
math Tyler at the point that someone
that the two of you on any issue as a
married couple cannot
find some common ground off of actual
data that indicates the behavior you're
engaging in raising kids or being
married or Building Wealth or having a
career you can't come into agreement on
that at some point you got to sit down
with a marriage counselor if you can't
get past that what you should do today
is write a check and pay off everything
foreign
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today
Chuck and Cindy are on the line for a
very special debt-free scream uh Cindy
are you with us
yep Chuck and I are both right here
hey Chuck I know you're not speaking to
me right now but I just want to tell you
hello so uh Cindy reached out to our uh
Ramsey concierge team and so did Chuck's
hospice nurse uh asking to as a hospice
wish
to uh to do their debt free scream and
that's how we got introduced to Chuck
and Cindy uh over the last uh couple of
weeks here around Ramsey and then got it
set up with Austin our associate
producer to do your all's debt free
scream today so uh Cindy let's start off
with how much debt you've paid
so we've paid off a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars and it was mostly just
mortgage stuff
um we had paid off some other stuff
after Chuck uh while Chuck was in
Afghanistan
um but we had paid off when we started
the Ramsey plan we paid off our mortgage
no you paid off your mortgage 120 000
how long did that take
about 75 months excellent excellent and
Chuck was in Afghanistan with the
military
he was he was what they call a dirt
sailor he was a Navy guy in the um
Afghanistan Arena as a basically a
middle manager because they didn't have
enough apparently so well thank you
thank you for your service Chuck we love
you we appreciate you all right now tell
us your story of how we get to this call
today and what's been going on with you
and Chuck
ugh
with
um terminal brain cancer called a
glioblastoma and
um
prior to that we had you know we had
been debt free and we're living our
lives and we're so happy enjoying our
lives
and um when he got sick
one of the things that I
um
that I was so grateful for was that we
were definitely on the Ramsay plan
because I didn't have a mortgage that I
had to stress about paying off or paying
at all like no mortgage payments we had
no Consumer Debt and we had our
um
we had six months worth of expenses set
aside and when he first got sick
I sold my car and
um our little pop-up camper in order to
move that to 10 months worth of expenses
of our normal expenses so
um
so that has that what a relief I mean so
let me get my timeline right so you were
debt free mortgage and everything before
June of last year
yes okay so you're a little you're a
little late to do your debt free scream
here but of course we got you on the
phone anyway right but so yeah so you're
100 debt free house and everything and
how old are you
um we are 55 and 56. okay and that all
happened and then he gets his diagnosis
yep in June yep okay yep
and uh and so since June we've been
fighting terminal brain cancer
yep wow
yep one day at a time and filled with
gratitude amen
amen uh but he he uh expressed to his
hospice nurse that he didn't ever do his
debt-free scream when he paid off the
mortgage and that was one of the things
he wanted to do
yep yeah he's not in his head
so what was this process like for you
guys as you attacked the mortgage
so
um we were probably a little different
than most other people because
we we did all of ours with
um
I'll say budgeting you know we were just
really way more attentive to the budget
um we had taught Financial Peace
University six times and each time we
were able to kind of look at our budget
a little bit differently with a slightly
different perspective and
um so we you know we we used our income
to pay down the mortgage and you know it
was basically an extra thousand dollars
a month or if there was you know
something else left in the budget at the
end of the month we're like okay well
let's throw that to the mortgage too
um you know because every Dollar's got
to have its name so you know we just
kept throwing any extra money that we
had in the budget towards the mortgage
okay
um
people often
say I don't want to work this get out of
debt plan I need to live my life because
life's short
and today we're talking about life being
short and yet you all you all sacrificed
to be debt free do you regret doing that
instead of spending all that money doing
something else
so no because we really lived our life a
lot I mean we went I mean we may have
gone camping instead of a four-star
hotel but we went places we traveled we
lived Our Lives we probably spent more
time doing some of those things that
people say oh I can't wait until I
retire and I can do whatever we really
focused on living Our Lives before he
got sick yeah and before you got the
house paid off even but then you're
still intentional with the budget and
dialed it in a little more every time
you taught FPU and still got the house
paid off yeah I just want I just want
because sometimes um
it's uh
I have never talked to anyone in 30
years of doing this that regretted
the sacrifice of getting out of debt
like they missed something because they
did that
you know what I'm saying no oh I I agree
wholeheartedly it has been the biggest
gift through all of this
um I actually I sent an email a while
ago to you guys and it it
it went through you know all the
different filters and said fill out this
form and I was like ah too much work
um I was a little lazy but um basically
the title of my email was thank you for
saving our bacon because truly if it
hadn't been for the Ramsey program I am
not certain
you know that I would have been able to
literally I just I walked out of work on
Thursday afternoon and um he had a
seizure on Friday morning and I never
went back never looked back was knew
that we'd be okay
yeah because because of the FPU program
and he I mean he's uh he's a good man
and he knows that you're going to be
okay
that is one of his biggest concerns was
he just wanted to make sure I would be
okay
yeah and you are
yep yep other than a broken heart which
I got with you and I'm trying to get
through this without crying too
sorry so we're barely be a blubbering
mess here together Chuck I'm just saying
buddy oh man
mild what what's your financial
situation look like now
with him being in hospice and you're not
working
um
the VA has stepped up
um there's a whole lot of behind the
scenes and if anybody wants that
information I will be very happy but
um between his work disability Social
Security disability and the VA
disability as well as the VA paying me
to be his caregiver
um we are
we are we are fine we are absolutely
fine yeah good good I'm glad to hear
that hon
well Chuck you're a hero man you served
your country you served your wife
and um
we are honored to do
a debt-free scream with you today
um
Pretty stinking incredible
all right Cindy you guys ready
are you ready Chuck yeah okay Chuck and
Cindy Raleigh North Carolina a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars paid off
house and everything counted down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one
weren't that free
we're a little quiet
as it should be
[Applause]
that's how it's done
man woo oh man oh man oh man
wow thank you both so much what a
special call I wanted to be a part of it
amen
wow
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
sometimes one of you will say Dave how
can we say thank you well I'll tell you
how
you want to say thank you for the show
and for the information and the
inspiration that comes from these
microphones there's an easy way to do
that
subscribe to the show hit follow or
subscribe on your YouTube button your
Spotify your Apple button whatever it is
share the show share the link to the
podcast share the radio station you
listen to us on tell your friends about
it uh and you know leave a review
a five-star review mama said if you
ain't got nothing nice to say don't say
nothing at all so there you go so leave
a review subscribe follow whatever that
process is and share it whatever medium
or media you listen to let people know
this is happening you're the secret
sauce as to why this has been successful
the Ramsay show is 30 years old and
we've never done any
marketing to amount to anything
never done any national advertising on
the Super Bowl ads or anything else to
tell people we're here the 25 million of
you that listen every week through the
various ways that we broadcast this are
all here because somebody told you about
it
thank you for that we appreciate you
very very much Samantha Is With Us in
Atlanta Georgia hi Samantha welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
so me and my husband got married a
couple months ago and we are working the
baby steps we
are on baby step four where we're trying
to invest and make sure our retirement's
all set up and going good but we're
running into a little bit of a debate I
guess between the two of us of trying to
manage investing the amount we need to
for retirement but also saving cash for
a house in the next couple years is our
real goal to have a good house down
payment
and get into a home so we're trying to
prioritize saving for a house down
payment versus you know following the
investing advice we need to as far as
Retirement so that's what I wanted to
talk to you about cool so what's your
down payment goal
so when we did the calculations with a
couple different calculators and you
guys's we feel like we have got
especially within this Market
it needs to be below 300K
um as far as like the total for the
house so we're trying to save up I mean
five percent of that would obviously be
the minimum but we want to do more if we
can okay so 15 000 minimum and if you
continue investing your 15 how long
would it take you to get fifteen
thousand dollars on top of that
that's what we're trying to figure out
we actually just started Financial Peace
so we're trying to get together a budget
um but I guess built into this question
is like for my company I have a 401k
that I'm already investing 15 into but
for him he just got a new job where he
doesn't have a 401k offer and so he was
offered a stock option and we didn't
know if he should be investing into that
or what we should do to make sure we're
still investing what we need to
well he'll also have the option for an
IRA which will be outside of his
employer that you guys can max out to
get to that 15 and it's just 15 percent
of household income and so if it needs
to be weighted towards your 401k plus
your two IRAs you can do it that way but
the discussion here is really about how
soon are you real you're really wanting
to be homeowners and if you want to take
down your investing a little bit to do
that to speed up the down payment
process you can do that I would rather
find other ways to do it like increase
income to get there personally
but there's no right or wrong here as
long as you're not pausing investing for
a period of longer than two years
okay so if I'm having my 15 and my
company 401K you stop all retirement
temporarily for two years and pile up
money for your down payment that's what
we call baby step 3B and that fits
within our plan
it's a temporary thing because you're
gonna you got plenty of time how old are
you guys
26 and 27. okay and so you know you're
you're 28 and 29 and you start investing
15 of your household income into
retirement and you have a fully funded
emergency fund and no debt except the
house and now you're a homeowner this is
two years from now you're going to be
very very wealthy you'll be just fine
or you can say you know we're going to
continue to put less than 15 percent of
household income in but we're going to
put something in to retirement and
that's going to slow down or limit the
amount of our down payment in our three
what we call 3B in other words after
baby step three of the emergency fund
then we start saving for a house and
then and what people do during that time
is they put 0 to 15 percent of their
household income into retirement
anywhere between zero and fifteen
percent for that two-year period of time
is fine and then then you get the house
bought and you put a solid 15 in there
you start working kids college if you've
got kids on the way by then and um and
you start working to pay off that
mortgage then is baby step six as you
have already discovered so the truth is
you're not really ready to answer this
question because you haven't even done
your budget yet
and you haven't looked at how long it's
going to take all you did is you pick
out a house range of 300 000 and you've
still got you know you got retirement
accounts kind of lingering back from
before you were married and he just got
a new job and we just started FPU and
we're trying to learn all this so just
it's okay just breathe
just sit right there do your budget
together and then decide okay we're
going to put nothing into retirement for
a short period of time build up our
build up our down payment really fast or
we're going to put 10 or 8 percent and
they're gonna build it up a little
slower or we're going to put the full 15
in and like George said we're gonna take
a side hustle of some kind or something
and get the income up to build the down
payment that way any of that is okay any
that's okay you just don't want to have
nothing going into retirement for 20
years
you don't want to have uh everything
going into retirement 25 going into
retirement or 30 of your income going
into retirement and never save up a down
payment for a house so
you've you've just gotten married now
we're getting a house now we're getting
a new job you got a lot going on you're
going to get there just just breathe a
little bit by this time next year you're
going to be really in stride you're
going to have a rhythm to this and
you're going to be able to lay these
goals out very clearly from Financial
Peace University you're doing really
really good really good start there
Tyler's in Fresno hey Tyler welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey how's it going better than we
deserved
how can we help yeah so so I just got
involved with uh with the whole Ramsey
experience and and I guess uh my biggest
question to you is
so I'm right now I'm 70 000 in debt
um 29 000 of that is through a 401k loan
that that I've taken out on myself
and I'm wondering since I'm paying that
back to myself
do is that still part of the snowball or
or how should I how should I classify
that yes all Consumer Debt which we
would classify that 401k loan as
Consumer Debt would fall into the debt
snowball the only thing that wouldn't is
your mortgage and sometimes a HELOC if
it's a huge huge huge number so what
other debt do you have and how much is
it sorry we lost you on the line there
no okay try again all right nope how
much debt is it you got it
so the total total of 70 000 in debt and
uh that comes from 29 of it like I said
being the 401K loan
and then the other debt I have 11 000
for my truck loan
uh I have
a dirt bike which is thirteen thousand
dollars and I have my wife uh Forerunner
which is also sixteen thousand dollars
what's your household income
uh so total
I'm my my annual is a 142
um and that's without overtime I'm
mostly make overtime and my wife's
um around 10 grand
okay so you probably make 160 a year
between overtime and her 10 grand give
or take
um and you've got seventy thousand
dollars and you got seventy thousand
dollars in debt so how fast does 70 go
away making 160.
pretty fast yeah
you guys have any money in the bank they
should you get any money saved
I do yeah so I have uh right now we we
have twenty two thousand dollars and
saved
Perfect You're Gonna apply that to your
debt snowball you just knocked out a
truck payment right there man yeah you
got rid of the 11 000 and got well on
your way on the next one down so yeah
just get it let's just get in gear man
let's get after it uh you're gonna be
debt free by Christmas if you'll load
this up and get after it
um that's plus or minus keeping the dirt
bike 13
000 I might sell that dollar dirt bike
that's a nice one
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Annie in Spokane Washington starts this
hour hi Annie welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
yeah so my husband and I have a slight
disagreement and the question is should
we pay our mortgage off and into your
savings account
um or
keep it alone for about 150 000 and then
do a few Home Improvements and that
would be a new Foundation windows and
HVAC system
okay so how much is in savings
okay and the balance on your mortgage is
what
six hundred thousand
okay you said six hundred and eight
thousand correct it would be this about
a month and a half to two months worth
of emergency fund if we pay off our
mortgage
you have an emergency fund in addition
to the 608. no the eight thousand the
eight thousand is a month and a half I
got you okay correct yeah yeah and your
household income is what
a 203 approximately about two hundred
and three thousand um and then also we
do have we're just signing a 10-year
lease for um some Farm ground and that
will bring in
um 30 000 a year for 10 years
okay so you have a quarter million
dollar income
and
[Music]
um
all right we do not tell people to pay
off debt and leave less than three
months of expenses
okay so let's fast forward from today
a couple of months and now you've got
600 and
30 000. okay
uh that day I would pay off my mortgage
okay and then I'm going to use this
fabulous income and the extra six
thousand dollars a month
to build up some little uh buckets of
money to do these Renovations that we
want to do
okay yep my husband uh he said that's
what you would say but well I'm fairly
predictable I've said it over and over
and over I say the same thing all the
time so I mean you can yeah you know so
here's the thing uh the other thing you
can do it'll help you with this Annie to
process it helps me when you actually
put numbers to it and then you put uh
how many months it's going to take me to
do this so I'm going to go ahead and get
like a bid on the heat and air I'm going
to get a bid on the foundation
I'm going to get a bid on what was the
other thing
Windows Windows okay and then I'm going
to say okay the first one of these we're
going to do is I'll make it up Windows
okay and the bid is thirty thousand
dollars
okay without a house payment and a
quarter of a million dollar income then
how quick do I have thirty thousand
dollars in addition to my emergency fund
oh just a couple of months I mean
got it yeah and then and then how quick
do I have you know the I'll make it up
twenty thousand dollars for the heat and
air if that's the second one I don't
care which one's first I'm making this
up okay but my point is prioritize and
put actual dollars to it and then back
into how many months and what you're
going to discover is probably by this
time next year you've got a fully
renovated paid for house
yeah
yeah perfect yeah so we're really not
discussing oh we're never going to get
around to this no lay it out yeah game
Planet develop a detailed strategy and
then that if I'm in your shoes because
you're the one not wanting to pay it off
you're the one wanting to do the
renovations first and that's okay but if
I'm you then having that game plan going
oh it's going to be here in a minute
anyway I can deal with that yeah it
helps me to release it okay yeah we're
talking about a month or two before you
guys have you know 625 in that account
and now we can clear the mortgage
payment which frees up the mortgage
payment on top of still having an
emergency fund there so it's not enough
time to even argue about Yeah it's
you're going to be there and and you
know I would you guys make a lot of
money and I would do the renovations
assuming you're not over building the
neighborhood with all that but I'm
guessing that you're probably going to
spend well less than a hundred thousand
dollars on those three items and it
sounds like the house is probably north
of a million in value and so it's not a
big deal and you make plenty of money to
do all this so really good job very very
good job these are the good things to
argue about these are good arguments
okay it's like oh we have six hundred
thousand dollars in savings do we pay
off the house what an argument most
people would like to have listeners are
shaking their fists right now going
really this is this is what we're
calling in about 600 Grand in the bank
amazing job it's a truly first world
problems but yeah yeah I mean it but the
point is you guys are neither one of you
are really wrong it's just a matter of
laying out a strategy to do this and
George I did this many years ago we were
just coming out of being broke we're
starting to get a little money finally
we're nearly to the point that Annie is
at this at this stage but we had a
little bit of money coming in and Sharon
had this uh we had little kids and we
had this God awful
two-tone blue Astro van do you remember
those oh yeah nasty looking little
vehicle and it was nasty inside because
it had three dogs and three kids in it
and seen some things you talk about
stuffed I mean nuclear waste was in the
floorboard so and this thing was bad and
Sharon's like gets this idea now we're
starting to get a little margin she's
like
I need a Suburban I need a new car
and I'm like yeah well I mean
you know Santa Claus needs reindeer too
but we're you know we're not knowing
what happened yeah I'm work doing stuff
down at the office I got I got an
investment I need to make down here to
get some more money coming in by doing
this thing and uh you know we got 20 000
bucks and we can either buy her a
Suburban or we can go use that 20 000
down here at the office and make some
more money
and um you know and we went at it
as if
if she got the Suburban I would never do
the investment or if I did the
investment she would never get the
Suburban and what we learned was what we
just taught Annie which is oh shut up
both are going to happen both are going
to happen fairly quickly
just decide which one's first
and flip a coin being the wise husband
that I am she got the Suburban first
and then I did the investment second but
it really I mean we about we had a big
old fight about it because we it was all
or nothing and it's not all or nothing
usually it's just it's not no it's not
now
no is not really what we're saying we're
saying not now we're not really saying
no we're not going to do the Heat and
Air in the windows and the foundation
it's not now that's the thing and uh
it's kind of like how children are when
they go well if it's not going to happen
now I'm going to throw a giant fit
because it's never going to happen yeah
and that's not what it's just which
one's first do we pay off the house or
do we do the renovations it's not an
either or we're going to do both let's
just decide the order
and which one makes the most sense
mathematically and emotionally and
relationally and all that right so there
you go I tried to Google a photo just
this picture Dave and Sharon Ramsey
driving oh that's not it is two-tone
that's not that's are we getting close
nicer we're getting closer that one's
nicer there you know that's that's the
you still didn't get it that's going to
be a new segment full-size fan there but
yeah that's gonna be your next car
that's closer but it was a lot uglier
than that that one's a pretty good
looking van I drive like no one else and
later you can drive anything you want
there you go babe wow there you go
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us triple eight eight two five five two
two five our Building Wealth live tour
continues February the 16th that sounds
suspiciously like what next week will be
in Indianapolis for tomorrow with uh
Rachel Cruz George Campbell Jade warshaw
and then we're heading over to Austin
Texas the next week with Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney and Jade warshaw this is me
on all of these April 24th I'll be
heading to Salt Lake City with Rachel
Cruz George Campbell and Christina Ellis
final stop is Anaheim May 2nd Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney me and Christina
Ellis tickets start at 49 you can get a
four pack starting at a hundred and
seventy five dollars we'll be signing
pictures answering questions doing panel
discussions talking about Building
Wealth
in 2023
it sounds weird out there right now but
you can actually win at money and you
can build wealth in the middle of this
craziness that we call the United States
today it can still be done our question
of the day comes from Teresa in Georgia
George take it Teresa is asking can you
all explain how you think about Home
Improvement loans to increase the size
of your house versus buying a bigger
home that is more expensive logically I
do not understand how it's different to
increase your mortgage versus taking on
a home loan so you do not have to move I
think your advice would be to increase
mortgage and move versus taking on a
home equity loan but I don't understand
how it's different both mathematically
and logically I have no debt but my
house and I have a fully funded
emergency fund
interesting
so she's saying hey I have a home why
not just take the HELOC and do Home
Improvements versus moving and buying a
bigger home
well number one Home Improvements
usually can be cash flowed
uh and so she's right in that regard now
if you're going to do a
two hundred thousand dollar Improvement
you're gonna add a wing to this thing
okay uh that's something most people
can't cash flow in that case you might
take out a loan and then refinance and
have a permanent Mortgage in place when
you're done however what normally
happens in a situation like that is
you're making another mistake which is
you're overbuilding the neighborhood
and if you become the most expensive
house on the neighborhood with a weird
200 000 Wing you're not going to get
your money back out of it the home value
didn't increase by 200 Grand is what
you're saying because the neighborhood
is limiting it so let's say you're in a
uh neighborhood that running runs three
to four hundred thousand dollars and
your home is currently worth three
hundred thousand and you put an
improvement on it of 200 000. you now
have to get 500 000 in a neighborhood
that people don't look for five hundred
thousand dollar homes they're looking
for three or four hundred thousand
dollar homes in that neighborhood they
don't if they got five hundred thousand
they don't come to your neighborhood
uh but and so plus your house at that
point unless you're an incredible
remodeler an incredible architect you
generally are building a weird structure
I mean when you start doing stuff like
that so uh you know we need a our family
is growing and we need another you know
we need some more rooms you very often
run in the situation where you're over
building the neighborhood but that's a
different problem than logically I don't
understand the difference so if you were
doing a
something that's just out of range of
cash flow and are not over building the
neighborhood uh you know you're you're
still going to be the uh not the most
expensive home in the area and you're
not building a weird structure you're
not messing up in another way uh and you
were to refinance a home equity loan uh
after you did this into a permanent
mortgage and one mortgage then there is
no difference and I'm we're not against
that but I got to tell you the number of
times that happens that you don't end up
violating one of these other things is
so small usually a bad decision is made
somewhere here in the process yeah
and and you know basically you know I
emotionally don't want to move I don't
want to leave this area but I want a
house that's bigger than this area
supports
and has more uh attributes than this
area supports value-wise and and so you
know what we're usually doing is kicking
you out for your own good and putting
you into a neighborhood that fits your
new needs and you know but
mathematically logically
yeah it sometimes could work and we're
not against you doing that but um but
you know let's say you're doing a twenty
thousand dollar rehab and you make a
hundred thousand well just shut up and
budget it
I mean save up the money and do it
that's not that's within that's within
cash flow reach yeah it's not where it's
going and you wouldn't move up twenty
thousand dollars in house either so
that's not part of her it's not one of
her examples it wouldn't fit with her
example so good question Home
Improvements I mean it's a good
clarification that she brings I like it
Tim is in Pittsburgh hey Tim what's up
uh thanks for taking my call sure my
question is
at uh at the age of 69 does it make
sense to
backdoor a Roth IRA
if you're going to leave the money alone
if you're going back to it and turn
around take it out the front door no
okay yeah this is this is money now
probably never need exactly you're going
to leave it as an inheritance
and if you leave if you if you live you
know 10 20 years
79.89 which you're very likely to do
unless you're unhealthy right now
uh statistically you are anyway
uh then okay then you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna have you're gonna be
really glad plus the Roth IRA Now does
not require rmd does not require uh
required minimum distributions at 73
like a traditional does
okay so you're able to just leave it or
for assistance would I go to a uh you
know a tax person or no you go to one of
our smartphones now you go to an
investment broker one of our uh advisors
that we recommend they don't work for us
but they're called Smart Vista pros and
they're people on the mutual funding
business and they'll help you get one
open and help you do the back door and
uh run that out so but the math works
out that if you're going to leave it
alone 10 plus years the Roth comes out
ahead and it sounds like you're going to
leave it alone that long uh and because
you don't have to touch it at 73 because
it's not there's no rmds anymore on that
no required minimum distributions the
new secure act and by the way that
secure act uh is there's a big blog on
it the secure 2.0 act it's a big blog at
ramsesolutions.com and you can read that
blog post and learn a lot about it did a
lot of interesting things to retirement
and almost all of it's good a few weird
things but we got we have a really good
thorough article on that but
um but so and what's a backdoor Roth IRA
so this is a great tool when you want to
maximize your wealth and the traditional
IRA has income limits and so if you are
at a point where you've maxed out a lot
of these retirement tax advantage
accounts you can open up a traditional
IRA you can Max that out and then you
convert those funds to Roth meaning you
pay the taxes at that point but then you
never pay them again
yeah so actually you open an after tax
credit after tax traditional and
instantaneously roll it to a Roth IRA I
do one every year
um and I'm I'll be 63 this year so I
keep doing them and for those that go
well when do I do this in the process
only do this once you're kind of a baby
step seven yeah with a paid for house if
you've got a big tax implication I'd
rather see those funds used to pay off
your mortgage versus convert the funds
your household income's over 200 000 you
don't qualify for Roth IRA anymore and
so the only way you can get a Roth IRA
is open and after tax traditional and
roll it to a Roth and uh it's actually a
weird little loophole in the law and
they've never figured out a way to close
it so they threatened it there was some
threats and people got spooked but they
haven't done anything yeah it won't
matter it won't go back and undo the
ones we've already done it just won't be
able to do it going forward if they ever
stop it up but for now that loophole is
there and that works for those of you
making more than
200 000 if you're at the point that you
want to put more into retirement and
George said normally that's a baby step
seven
that you're trying to get there and do
that so I do anything I can do to keep
the government's hands off of money
because if you haven't noticed they're
stupid
they're stupid and we don't want to give
stupid people money
so anything that's legal keep their
hands off of it because I don't want to
give stupid people money they're stupid
well it's a tax trade and spending is my
tax time passive aggressive nature I
mean aggressive aggressive nature coming
out Dave gets grouchy every April have a
passive aggression I'm impressive
aggressive oh there's like the
Punxsutawney Dave six more weeks of
grouchiness until tax season's stupid
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Kevin and Sherry are with us
hey guys how are you how are you welcome
where do y'all live we're out of Denver
Colorado Denver welcome to Nashville
thank you sir and how much debt have you
guys paid off I was a little over 98 000
in uh about 22 months wow and your range
of income during that two years oh about
155 to about 210. wow good for you what
do you all do for a living I'm in the
I.T networking space I work for a large
investment and banking firm cool and I
worked for Hobby Lobby during that time
oh great very good good for you guys
well well done what kind of debt was the
98 000. uh just as you say everything uh
kind of normal some credit card debt
couple vehicles uh Home Improvement
stuff that we obviously didn't pay for
in cash so yeah normal stuff there you
go you were normal yeah and how long you
all been married oh 23 years so after 23
years of marriage after 21 years of
marriage you're sitting here with normal
amounts of debt what was the wake-up
call how did you get onto this Ramsey
stuff go ahead so actually I wanted to
do this way back about probably 20 years
ago when we kind of our kids were first
born come on Kevin
slow learner we I
had had a friend introduce me to
Financial Peace University and she
actually shared her CDs with me let me
listen to it I was like let's do this I
bought envelopes I started it and every
time he would be like oh he'd go spend
money I'm like that's not in the budget
what are you doing and he was I don't
know I don't want to do this so we
actually went through some marital
issues and that really kind of got us
some got us going so yeah I'll let him
finish the rest yeah so we went through
those problems and she had even moved
moved out of the house and you know
pretty pretty rough times and as we uh
started working on that and all the
other you know other problems we had
this was you know finances was one of
them and um and I was I was on board
right we gotta get gotta get our
marriage right so uh we we did that and
it's been uh full bore ever since good
for you thank you that's incredible yeah
you said it's whatever I got it whatever
it takes to do the marriage right yeah
and being on the same page on the money
is one of the elements and I want to put
this together and I'm going to sacrifice
my uh my pride yeah and go do that I I
was I'm good for you that's it right
it's good for you it's all of us I mean
we're all do that yeah good for you
though that's really Manning up I'm
proud of you thank you appreciate it
very cool I was hollering at you a
minute ago
so what did this financial
transformation look like when you said
all right I'm willing to do whatever it
takes what's next
really it was him taking over the
finances so I used to do all the bill
paying and stuff like that and so he
kind of took it over and he created a
budget and then started listening to you
guys and was like okay is your mind just
blown when you saw him sitting down
doing the budget himself yes and then
now he usually gets upset with me
because he's like why don't you look at
the budget with me I'm like I don't care
just tell me what it is
wow this is a complete turn I finally
applied the uh engineering job you know
thinking in mind to to that and now I
probably overdo it I'm I'm in my budget
she daily so yeah well I mean it's a
formula and it's a process that works
yes and that's what engineering is yeah
and so it's a it is a natural way for
your brain to work yes it does line up
with that that's funny and now it's
completely turned around and you're like
would you get in here and do the budget
yeah
but and it really has helped our
marriage a ton just I mean I can't
express that enough like I didn't feel
like the finances we're proud part of
our problem or the main part of our
problem but just that communication and
working through the finances together
a lot of marriage counselors use
getting a couple on a that are having
marriage trouble on a budget because
it's not about the budget it's about
where your money goes is your dreams
it's your values it's your fears and so
it's when you're you're agreeing on your
life when you're agreeing on your money
it's not that the the money problem but
the fact that you weren't agreeing on
your monies you weren't agreeing on the
other stuff too yes and I I mean we we
always knew we were blessed to make what
we made and uh but yeah where where is
it going how you know and for us it was
we'd end every year and I'd get a bonus
and we'd pay off debt and then a few
months into the year we'd already start
with that so yeah well I don't know who
did your marriage counseling but they
did a great job you look like a couple
of newlyweds I'm impressed they said 23
years married I was like wow yeah I mean
you look like it's all fresh and new and
that's cool for the last couple years
yeah it kind of feels that way yeah in
the 22 months of getting out of debt it
correlates with the healing yeah of and
you moving back in and all that right
yeah absolutely oh wow that is powerful
guys thank you so we're a a little piece
of the story of an awesome story about a
marriage being redeemed yep walking in
here I set it to to Cherie it's uh like
uh you know meeting some some friends
because I listen to you every day and so
it's like oh it's cool to see you guys
and meet you so just us yeah just
exactly we devastatingly exactly what
you expect yeah so oh my goodness so
Sherry this was a 20-year Journey for
you it's a little bit newer for Kevin
was there a thing that the knob turned
when I listened to the show I read the
book I went to Financial Peace what was
the thing for you where you went light
bulb on I've got it you mean when I like
before when Kevin finally got on board
20 years later was there a thing that he
connected to where he went that's it I
get it now or is it just the Rock Bottom
moment of the marriage I think that was
it I think it was that I think that he
was not well willing to give up and I
wasn't willing to give up either but we
just couldn't figure it out and that was
the that was the thing we needed was to
get on board on that so it made a big
difference for us I I think you know we
we had kids very young uh even before we
were married and maybe that's where some
of the you know things you know started
wrong but
um of course having our kids wasn't
wrong but um you know then looked at it
and thought gosh we have so much life
ahead of us right and we I want to enjoy
the things that we've worked hard to
enjoy and have been blessed with and you
know that was a big part of it too I
wanna you had a vision for your life
yeah I want to enjoy it with my friend
right my best friend my wife so that's
awesome and who are your biggest
cheerleaders on this journey
but really we did it yeah it sounds
weird we really did on our own most
people in our life were naysayers kind
of like this is not why are you you know
yeah and kind of like even like why are
you doing that a lot we got that like
you know I would say something to
someone in my family and they'd be like
I don't know why you're doing that like
that's crazy like why so we kind of just
got on board and just made it work
enough trying to get anybody to be
positive we'll just move on yeah that's
good good for y'all thank you how's it
feel now that you're free amazing yeah
it really is what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is uh I mean
Dave for me it's a few things right but
it's
um
being a a latino man
um you know not listening to the
narratives that are out there and and uh
you know hard work what our parents you
know my folks series folks hard work
honesty
um you know doing what you need to do
and that's got us to where we are and so
that's the key right that discipline and
what you teach is is that discipline and
stability so that's that's the key to me
yeah way to go you guys way to go hey we
got the live and give bundle for you
that's thank you Total Money Makeover
book thank you the baby steps
millionaires book and I won your
membership to Financial Peace University
thank you you can go through it you can
give it away maybe other people are
inspired by your overall story and the
money part of it you can help them with
buying them one of those things thank
you that's awesome good job man
congratulations you guys are neat thank
you thank you I'm so proud of you we
appreciate it very very well done Kevin
and Cherie Denver Colorado 98
000 paid off in 22 months making 155 to
210 oh and they saved their marriage
count it down let's hear a debt free
screen
okay
this is how it's done
what a journey it took 23 years to
decide to do something for 22 months
that set them up for Freedom interesting
I mean it's just wild when you think
about it that way are you willing to
sacrifice for just this much time or do
you want to suffer for the next decade
or two in mediocrity you get to decide
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day John 8 32 then
you will know the truth and the truth
will set you free
Sojourner Truth said truth is powerful
and it prevails
is that a person that name that's where
it sounds sounds right I think I've
heard that before okay what do I know
all right ah
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today Ron is with us in
Philadelphia Hey Ron welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um well uh about coming up on two years
now I came out of a divorce had to sell
the home moved back in with my parents
um it's getting kind of uh long that uh
find him at home uh I've completed the
first three of your baby steps after
finding your Total Money Makeover book
and reading it front to back uh pretty
quick and uh I just want to know if I
should just
like put everything into savings for a
down payment on home or or if I should
do four five and six like you suggest
okay we also suggest baby step 3B in The
Total Money Makeover do you remember
that
uh
vaguely I'll stop my head is just uh I
yeah okay 3B is where you would save up
for a down payment you already have the
emergency fund you have no debt and so
you can really focus in for you know a
few years to save up that down payment
and if you want to invest you know we
people invest from zero to fifteen
percent while doing that it just depends
on how aggressive you want to be in
getting that house
so I have about 40
000 saves for a down payment and I'm
just
it's it's been two years and I'm just
trying to start a new life with a new
woman in my life and so just get out
there and be a family again so are you
renting right now
no I live rent free with my family so I
mean it's great it's helping me so much
that I can put
four to six thousand dollars a month
away in savings it's just how old are
you daunting like I'm 37 okay and what
do you make a year
uh without overtime probably 70 this
past year I made about a hundred okay
and you have 40 000 cash and you live in
your parents house at 37 years old
yeah okay go rent an apartment or go buy
a house
I don't care which if you're not ready
to get the house then I'm renting while
continuing to save up the down payment
and don't buy a house with the new woman
in your life unless you're married to
her
gotcha because you're going to get
yourself in another mess okay
um so uh you know if you want to wait
until you're married and then the two of
you go pick out the house then you would
rent an apartment does that make sense
yes but I think it's going to be great
for you the relationship with her uh
everything just to get on out of there
you've done a great job you've gotten on
your feet and you're feeling
um antsy you're feeling the need to jump
from the nest and so uh Uncle Dave's
gonna push you fly and be free
Rachel's with us in St Louis hi Rachel
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi thank you
so much for taking my call I'm super
excited I am a homeschooler mom of a
sophomore daughter and we are doing the
foundation University personal finance
class during the Ramsey Network very
cool love it oh my gosh awesome class
and we just watched borrowed future
George oh my goodness you're getting
your teacher's pet today okay so my
daughter is starting her first job at 16
and the personal finance class and the
joys of compound interest has really
caught her attention and I would like to
help her find some type of high-yield
account that she can start with
um and I have no idea where to start and
so I was hoping you could maybe make a
suggestion for something online that
would be safe and appropriate for a 16
year old okay I'm sorry are you wanting
her to just save up a pile of cash for
her next goal like a car or college
education
yes she is actually we have her college
education stage four
um through 529
um because she's going to do a state
school and do school smart with
scholarships and then state tuition and
so with that we are good so this money
would be for probably Life After College
to start her life okay so she's
intrigued with the
with the uh the compound interest tables
and the understanding of Jack and Blake
and all that kind of stuff and she sees
that and wants to get that kind of stuff
going
yeah absolutely more than more than I'm
trying to save up to buy a car in
September
fun okay so the uh let me give you the
the truth and then I'll tell you what to
do to scratch your itch okay the truth
is nothing she does right now is going
to cause that to happen
okay the knowledge that she has if she
applies that as she comes out of college
starts a family has an adult household
income and in her 20s begins to apply
the baby steps stays out of debt Builds
an emergency fund and starts jacking up
that 401k in that Roth IRA that's what's
going to make her a millionaire probably
in her 30s
but it's not really going to be that she
puts her Chick-fil-A income working at
Chick-fil-A into a something at 17.
that's really not what's going to get
her there but I want her to do it anyway
okay okay so now that we've established
this is not going to make her a
millionaire but instead the knowledge is
going to make her a millionaire later
then that changes our the pressure of
this now what we're really doing is not
a an investment for the sake of Building
Wealth we're doing an investment as an
object lesson from the home school
so she can actually see the Practical
thing happen that she studied and that
scratches her itch as well it gets her
started but the truth is she's not gonna
put enough money in there at this age
to become a millionaire unless she's
some kind of
Wonder child or something you know she's
what is she doing for work
um she's working at a local ice rink
yeah she's going to be a Smart escape
guard type yeah Escape guard money
doesn't make you a millionaire when
you're 17. okay but it will help you
start a mutual fund and you can learn
how they work and you'll be way ahead of
the curve which is what happened when
you taught her these lessons to start
with she's way ahead of the curve so
just jump online at ramsesolutions.com
and click on the smartvestor pro in your
area they love teaching Teenagers by
opening their first mutual fund and they
don't make squat on it they make 15 on
it or something I mean it's not because
again it's not enough money to to screw
with but it's a great thing because it
gets her brain started on this and then
you know when she's dating some guy who
goes oh mutual funds are stupid and I'm
going to run up my credit cards she goes
you're not the one you know because
we've got this thing laid out and so
what we're doing is the the same thing
we're extending what you've already done
at with the homeschool lessons from
foundations yeah but it's
you know what you really do in high
school is not what gets you there it's
the things you learn that you apply as
you enter adulthood and it's creating
those habits and that muscle that's
going to get her there and there's a lot
of things you can do from short-term
savings a high yield savings account or
money market account you could do the
mutual fund
this is an object lesson I would do a
mutual fund in a taxable brokerage yes
okay because there's also custodial Roth
IRA but that's retirement nope wouldn't
do that I just would open a mutual fund
just go get growth fund of America or
whatever put 100 bucks in it and just
well it takes a thousand to get it open
or whatever but get it open learn how to
read the statements learn how to sit at
the desk with the investment advisor
smartvestor Pro learn the lingo watch
the statement watch how the share price
goes versus what you hear on the news
what you know and have the emotional
experience of all of that but that
thousand dollars or that two thousand
dollars that goes in there from Ice Rink
guard money is again not going to be the
cause mathematics quickly of your wealth
but you're setting the pattern in your
life and the knowledge base in your life
that is going to cause that and what a
great parent I know absolutely man what
great parenting Rachel you're a star
you're amazing well done
that puts us out of the Ramsay show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace
Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]